okay so the topic of this video today is
going to be rna and the process of
transcription so let's go ahead and get
started
so let's begin to break down the process
of transcription the process of making
rna in yellow that's a gene pretend a
segment of our dna with coded
instructions to build a protein the a's
t cs and g's those are the instructions
and during transcription those dna
atc's and gs are going to be copied into
rna
and so this is going to begin with an
enzyme called rna polymerase this
weirdly shaped object right here is
going to be symbolic of rna polymerase
and it's going to start to separate the
dna helix it's going to attach itself to
the dna and it's going to start to pry
open the a's from the t's and the c's
from the g's here we go
as rna polymerase continues down the
double helix it gets unzipped even
further
so now that we've unzipped the dna a
little bit we can move on to step number
two free floating rna nucleotides are
going to match with the dna
so rna polymerase the enzyme it will pry
open the dna and then transcription will
happen on only one of the two dna
strands we're going to do transcription
on the bottom strand so notice how the
first letter on the bottom is the yellow
t and so in floats and a for adenine a
bonds to t we're used to seeing that now
the next one is an a you might expect
the t to float in next but now it's
actually it's a u for uracil because
we're making rna rna has the letters a u
c and g there's not going to be any of
my t's any there's not going to be any
t's that float in when we do
transcription
the third letter is a c so in float's a
g
the next one is a g so in floats a c and
we have begun the process of
transcribing
and making a copy of the dna
we're going to make a copy of the dna
into rna
so notice that the enzyme just cut open
more of the dna helix and that is that
has exposed more
uh more room to do transcription
so notice how an a is floating in notice
how a g is floating in
free-floating nucleotides are going to
match
to the exposed dna
and again you may have been exposing it
you may have been expecting a t
just now but notice how u for uracil
came in because we're making rna now in
a moment you're going to see why some
letters are capitalized and others are
lower case that's not important right
now you'll see that in a little bit
and so notice how the enzyme keeps
cutting open the dna
and then nucleotides free floating
nucleotides are coming on in and bonding
well let's add another step to
transcription step three eventually near
the back end
near the left in this case the rna is
going to break free
so the rna is beginning to break free
but the enzyme rna polymerase is going
to keep unzipping the dna
and now that the dna has been unzipped
some more we can add some more rna
nucleotides a c floats in
another c floats in a g floats in
another g floats in so we're performing
transcription we're making rna
and eventually the rna
the the red our reddish brownish rna is
going to continue to break away
and now
also i want to add that you know the dna
will begin to recombine the yellow
unzipped dna at the left will begin to
recombine
and as we continue through the process
dna on the right hand side is going to
continue to be unzipped
and now we can add more nucleotides can
you predict what's next
a g what comes after this
an a what comes after that
a c what comes next
and a and what comes next
a u
well eventually the rna in reddish brown
is going to continue to break away
and the dna in yellow is going to
continue to re-zip
and now that we're at the final three
nucleotides
uh we're going to start to wrap this up
so the rna is going to continue to break
away
and the dna is going to continue to
re-zip
we can now add
the final three nucleotides we can add
the u
and the g
and the a the final three nucleotides
and of course the rna is going to
continue to break away
and the dna in yellow is going to
continue to re-zip
and eventually all the rna is going to
break away
and eventually all the dna is going to
zip back together
and so now that we've transcribed this
gene we turned it from dna to rna well
what comes next
well let's focus just on the rna this
rna is not final this is not finished
rna this is what is known as pre-rna it
has to be processed notice there's some
capitalized letters and some lowercase
letters now we're going to see why those
are there
so near the end of transcription there's
an event called rna processing and in
the key i just labeled the uppercase
letters to be something called xns and
the lowercase letters to be something
called introns
and so the introns turn out to be
some non-coding regions
of nucleotides that are cut out and
discarded they don't code for a protein
so they're just going to be cut out
discarded thrown away and those are the
lowercase introns
the capital letters represent the exons
and these are the coding regions these
are the regions of the nucleotides that
actually code in the formation of a
protein
so there's kind of this little special
protein complex enzyme
combination called a spliceosome
and it it takes the pre rna and it
starts reading it starts reading until
it finds an intron
and then it begins to cut out
the intron
and discard it
the exons are then
bonded together
and the spliceosome will continue
continue continue
until it finds another intron another
set of lowercase letters and the
spliceosome will then
start to cut out
these introns as well
and eventually the exons
are spliced back together
and now we have the mature rna the
processed rna this rna is now ready for
use
so what's going to happen with this rna
well let's pretend we just made
messenger rna
if this is messenger rna mature
messenger rna it's going to exit the
nucleus and go find a ribosome
so here's the mature messenger rna it's
exiting the nucleus and entering into
the cytoplasm
and so here's a ribosome and here comes
our mature messenger rna
the ribosome
can start to read the mature messenger
rna and as it's reading the rna
the ribosome is going to begin the
process known as translation and it's
going to start to collect a bunch of
bunch a bunch of amino acids and link
them together these amino acids will
eventually make
and form a protein again that's the
process of translation we're not going
to go into translation in this video
but i have another video if you are
curious so notice how once transcription
is over that immediately leads to the
next process beginning called
translation
so there you go i hope you found that
video helpful here's a little practice
quiz to kind of practice what you
learned in this video and i hope you
find this helpful if you're in my
biology class you know bring your
answers on a separate sheet of paper i'm
happy to check your answers before
school or after school one day thanks
for watching